the Wonder block or Pioneer puzzle a set
of dollhouse furniture cleverly carved
from just one block of wood let's put it
away for storage notice a little cubby
hole here well these two child seats
will fit together into one nestled shape
that can be slid underneath this chair
see you later guys wait I can still see
you don't worry this chair can be turned
upside down and placed on top bye-bye
next we're going to take this foot stool
and Slot it in just like that then we're
going to take this little ottoman and he
is going to plop in then this tiny
little foot stol goes right in there and
what is this this thing on the desk well
it can be whatever you want it to be
there is a way to use these pieces to
build a reindeer maybe I'll show you
that some other day he's going to fit in
right there then we carefully tip the
whole thing over pick up the desk and
sheath everything for storage the
Pioneer
puzzle